well we Kardashian and Tristan Thompson
have split due to trust issues a source
tells ET quote there were trust issues
again and she has been down that road
before she has to be strong for herself
and true adding everyone is extremely
disappointed this comes 10 months after
Tristan and Chloe's relationship
dominated headlines when Tristan
reportedly cheated on Chloe with
multiple women while she was nine months
pregnant with their first child together
daughter true hold on Chloe's texting me
right now I'll call you back hey are you
okay do you want me to come down there
keeping up with the kardashians
documented the cheating scandal and
subsequent fallout it's just why her
like it just it really really sucks
they're both in the same house right now
no she kicked him out he's like well he
left the house we're trying to get her
to come home despite the continued
conflict the pair reconciled and stuck
together we love Tristan so much and
she's so happy and she's been through so
much should have and be in such a great
place in her personal life is amazing
until multiple reports speculated on
Tuesday that Kylie's BFF Jordan woods
was at the center of the latest drama
claiming that Tristan cheated on Chloe
with her the 34 year old reality star
commented with multiple emojis on a
Hollywood unlocked Instagram post
reporting the news the best friend
Malika Haqq also commented writing
strong facts and family friend Larsa
Pippen chiming in with a men following
the reporting Tristan had commentary of
his own tweeting quote fake news this
story is still developing so keep it
locked in at ET online.com for the
latest
[Music]